all right
gin and tonic
watch this that's a gin and tonic no i
mean the giant penis straw in my drink
you think that's giant
is that giant tea
look can i just have a regular straw
yeah i don't think so we uh we had a
bachelorette party in here last night
and we ordered about 500 of these things
they used four or four of them and uh
we're trying to be green or in this case
a realistic light pink
i'm gonna pay for a drink i don't want
there to be a penis in it
okay
how about i make it up to you how about
a
free hat huh isn't that fun aren't we
having fun at a bar now
what planet are you from
say uranus what planet are you from
what planet say uranus would you please
just give me a drink okay
oh my gosh it's one of the bachelorettes
from last night she's still here she
must be housed you want to meet her uh
no i'm married
hey sheila
you want to kiss me on my flat face
let's get the engine primed before the
main comes huh
oh yeah
this just turned into a salad bar and my
salad needs some tossing it's low carbon
gluten free
glute gluteus maximus very inappropriate
you want some chicken to the scene stop
it stop the doctor stop it
no what are you doing
did you see her
was she here
was the woman here
you met her yes it was very
inappropriate oh hey no i'm sorry you
know i overstepped my bounds but let me
make it up to you can i can i get you a
shot on the house
sure
it's a nice luge
open your mouth
the pete home show premieres october
28th after conan only on tbs
meet pete at petehomes.com oh my god
call the doctor
sweetheart it's red again
it's like mr freeze i
had too much cranberry juice
but i love it